Super Smash Bros. Director Masahiro Sakurai
I'm back in the studio As you can see, I rented a large studio that is even different from the usual studio, and the
staff are already looking at it from a very long distance. From the
fighting game series Tekken.  1 Kazuya Ma is participating
in the war I have already announced it directly, but I will revisit Kazuya's normal skills
[Music]
Yeah Yeah Yeah
This is Tekken
Well, I have to introduce that Tekken first, so I'll reconsider
it. The arcade game released in December 1994 is
a 3d fighting game using the masterpiece Polion, and both hands are expressed by ordinary buttons.  The
latest work is Tekken 7 Numbering is 7, but there are also types such as tag tournaments and
there are more actual titles
One day I heard the voice of heaven It
may be from Tennoji or the company that is in
it  I wonder how you translate it overseas, but
yeah yeah yeah, according to that voice, let Tekken agree with Smash Bros.
Although it is common to defeat the opponent with punches and kicks, it is
different for each genre in terms of game design.
It is not a matter of common discussions and divisions that just entered whether Smash Bros. is a fighting game, but the essence of the game.  It
's like a game design theory, but
Tekken is a hit of Ito characters, and it's a trick when it's composed of the attributes of the upper, middle,
and lower tiers.  It's a
game of coordinates that are
required. The new abilities required are also quite different.
Also, the net in the standard fighter on Mars is equivalent to the start of a fast technique
. There is a speed difference of 5 times.
It's possible to go,
but
that doesn't mean that the work will be embodied in a new way.
It would be a shame to make it normally, but it
's a smartphone design to manage the unreasonableness with a punch.
There was one good story
No.
Tekken has a setting called Devil Factor
Devil drinking was possessed by Kazuya's mother Kazumi, who
literally can draw out the power of the
devil and has taken over the devil in child.
Debut drinking is in Kazumi and his son Hitoshi Kazama.
The
biggest reason why I didn't make the fighter in favor is here.
Also, as long as I see Tekken 7, it
seems that I can put in and out the power of the devil
instantly or partially.  I thought that if I replaced the power of the devil with the power of the devil, I
thought that it would be a problem even with a smasher.
Just press the b button. As
usual, the camera is a special one for development, and I will tell you that the balance etc. may cause damage to the product version
. The
normal technique is
the high speed that represents Devil Blaster Devil Kazuya.  Flying Beam In the
original, it was divided into several names, but in this work, the special move is usually
unified with the name
Beer Blaster.
Then, the power will be reduced by that amount. If
you pierce three people,
this child
will have a high hitting point.
It also receives information, such as the basic value. If you
hit it in the air, you can use it as a little pot or as a control of the city.
It's a strong technique, so if you think that the opponent's counterattack will not pass, you can hit more and more.
Especially for Kazuya who wants to approach the opponent, it is important to create a situation where you have to approach from the opponent.
I can say that, but
let's think about whether to use it for ourselves or to deal with it.
Of course, we can reflect it.
[Music]
Kyushu can also do it.
It is a punch that
comes out. Even if you hit it at a distance, you only play the opponent weakly, but if you
hit it near, you will hit the opponent and bring it down.
You can do more things. If the
opponent is in the air, you will play it again.
The shielded opponent will not come out. It will be
full of gaps. The
movement distance is short, but it can also be used for recovery.
Sasazawa Devil win It is a
relatively simple climbing technique, but the climbing altitude is high.
Normally, the number of jumps is low, but the height of the aerial jump that
also
becomes devilish.  It's high.
You can move forward and backward before and after climbing. The
chocolate you used is a little fluffy,
and you can also use it for shooting down.
If you
don't fall after the special move,
you can't use the horizontal special move or the upper special move again
. The special move is
to grab the opponent in front of the Heaven's Door and hit it against the ground.
As with Bowser's side-killing Aso, you can do anything with your opponent, but cars and others are supposed to be killed before your opponent, and if you are a
fighter with high resilience, you can return after being taxed.
You can also push it back with
You can grab the opponent inside or you can grab the opponent in the air. You can
connect or hold it with a combo to the winter opponent. Just in case, the combo is a
combination.
Also keep in mind that
Heaven's Door is also related to the gauge system introduced below. If the
accumulated damage exceeds 100% or the physical strength of the physical strength student is less than 1/4,
it will be in a state of rage only once.  The state that literally happened
The name display of the gauge also
changes.In this state, the attack power is the highest in the crack. That alone means that it is simple.
I see the
movement on the Heaven's Door, but the power is
different. There are three ways to do it.
Method 1 It's relatively easy to grab.
Use the special move Heaven's Door.
The stepping distance is longer than the normal Heaven's door.
Direction-san Shoryuken command + long press of attack button
This is the same as the minister who will explain later.
Only the command version has more power. The
button is 1 with the attack button.  The book can be anything there, but it should be gridded. The
Meiji state will be canceled if you use Daisy Drive,
etc. It will not be improved by time etc., but it will be canceled if you receive damage above a certain level
.
It means that if
you use the grab, the rage will disappear immediately.
If you aim, hit it properly. The
last ticket is Final Blaster Day.
By the way, this is your graveyard. In Japanese,
I'm saying such a cool thing, but I'm also doing that for Pikachu.
Is easy to involve a third party. On the
other hand, it will not activate unless the first beam hits.If there
is a difference in altitude, do your best with a take dog for the first shot.
The effect is great. If the
conditions are met, it may be possible to start from 0% of accumulated damage.
Next, I will introduce the normal technique, but before that, I
will explain the overall characteristics of Fighter Kazuya.
The
attack power is the 2nd overall. If you lose by hand, you may want to reverse the situation and
finally buy it.
However, it is inferior in terms of beach and attack range.
It's slower.
Overall, it's a lot of work and the length of reach. It
may be an agreement with the opponent who attacks in the aerial battle
.
You can also cover other things.
Like dragons and terry, you can use the nickname against your opponent.
This is like an ionized fighting game when you put in a back-input technique.
It
is not so effective, but
if the damage is small, it may be possible to stop the 100-split attack etc. It is
better to activate Super Well, which is strong against a part of the attack.  It's big. It
takes damage, but it may interrupt the opponent's attack. There is no hit stop
because it was not in the original
.
Hit stop is a production that stops a little at 1 o'clock.
I
implemented the original Tekken motion as it is and proceeded with the policy with the intention of fixing it later when necessary, but when I
tested it as it was, it was
surprisingly weak.
It's also iced here. In the
end, I'm processing various speeds and strengths, but sometimes I keep the original flavor as a concern
.
This way of falling is good, isn't it? I'm
changing the operation system from other fighters.  l Think of the stick input direction in 8 directions.
There are some things like command input.
Canceling the normal technique that is by far the most among all fighters
.  You don't have to master it.
I think you should find your favorite technique and expand it from there.
There is only one attack button as usual.
You don't have to press the four buttons corresponding to the pointer.
First, press the weak craft button in succession.  If you
are over the heel, the technique will change steadily.
This is not always the case due to the operation of the so-called 10-series combo opponent, but you can
easily launch a continuous attack with the touch
of a button.
It
is used when you want to blow off the opponent by attacking a little after the first shot. Remember the timing of
daddy papan. Pappa
dash attack
is indispensable for squeezing and hitting such opponents.
Dodge the attack and have a high flying power
. If you
defeat it twice quickly before attacking, the left heel will drop.
This has a little feature
that you can bounce the opponent's flying tool. It is
8 directions clockwise from here.
I think it's good to defeat the smash attack gently. It's good
to put it on the top and use it for the double upper
type or the attack of Taipei by approaching it
, but it is also effective to stop it with one shot and do part 2 in the future.
If you put it in and hit the attack button repeatedly, it's the exact opposite of the declaration.
If you hit the first floor, you'll almost certainly know everything.
It is good to make it in the magazine.
You can stop it in your mouth if you stop hitting repeatedly. It is a low 1
Baskenka kick with an attack while putting it sideways
.
As an
impression, I see it in the gallon animal hopper week. It looks
like this,
but in fact, the dross is a little faster.
If you hit it, it will blow away the opponent.
If you stop one shot, you can aim for other combos that make the opponent float. The
second shot has a feature that the seeds are sharpened greatly
.
If it is a seal, it may be possible to put out up to the second
shot.The tongue-in-the-neck attack has a relatively
long range because it attacks while advancing the fleece
.  If the opponent is
slanted behind the stimulus, the attack
will cause the pie to go down by. It is difficult to use in Kansai, but it
is recommended to combine it with the sideways deadly bubble child.
However, it is relatively strong as a leaf or a geisha, and
it is easy to use for combos, so
it is recommended
if you
can put it out.
If you don't have a full face to the corner, it will be a little easier to do.
It may
be difficult to use it with a smasher because the movement is even more invincible even if the legs are invincible. It may be good
to remember that all the running systems will not start combo.
The eyes are not connected to other techniques
.
Good evening, this is
a technique that comes out of crouching. It should be entered after the person has reached 3 properly, not in the direction
. If you
attack diagonally in front while crouching, it will spiral.  It
is good to use it as a counter because the posture is low and there is time like a view log. If you
attack while crouching, you will be jealous
.
Check and check  It
is a technique that the sit spin kick judgment lasts for a long time when attacking diagonally backward while
crouching, such as the guidance of the main office.
And although it is a special input, you can put out a genie sword by attacking while standing up from crouching,
but it suffered from the name of Rondrop's technique, but this is
a technique that strongly flutters the opponent with various combos.  You can do it, but what you want to aim for most is the horizontal
smash Akatsuki.
Depending on the opponent and the situation, you need to do another one, but
if you can shoot it down, it's a big chance.
Finally, it's a smash attack.
It is important to hit this for smash attacks anyway. It has
one of the best blow-off powers among fighters.
If you eat a little and make a clean hit, it will surpass even the Falcon punch
.  It doesn't become a clean hip when it's close
. It's iron that you hit firmly with a transparent fist.
The clean bold type is as direct as it is now.
Smash attacks are so, but there is a wife in the 2nd battle of Superma.
Horizontal smash attacks are the strongest
[Applause]
Increased smash attacks are Evil Twister.
It's enough. The
attack range is narrow, but you can also use the speed of occurrence to weave it into the combo
. It's better to close the case with a dash.
Also, there are few valuable technique options that can barely attack on the floor.
The mash attack is
used for the dragonfly according to the city kite hood place ritual, but
it
depends on the operation and situation, but various techniques are not connected.If the
opponent is vague, a horizontal smash attack may pass.
Actually, it has a meteo effect.
Also, I aim at the opponent who has a sword pattern from this position, but it is good to use it when the empress continues because the invincible time will be shortened every time I stay in the hole
.
There is also an
aerial attack. This is the same as a normal fighter,
up, down, left, right and neutral.
Normal aerial attack is a jump nack plan and kiss by Pure.
There is also a secret meteo judgment. The
front aerial attack
can be used mainly in ground battles using the knees of deteriorated customers.
Easy to use
Back aerial attack is
easy to blow off the opponent by jumping, but it is a little difficult to use because it turns around automatically at the time of doggie.
If you want to hit before, use it after dashing as usual.
Of course, it can be used as an effective means of attack against opponents
on the floor.The aerial attack
attacks the opponent with a shallow swoop attack.
You can barely use it for pursuit and return. If you aim, it will be
difficult for the second term if the elementary particles are too different from the top of the jump or the top of the aerial jump.
The
grab attack is Rokufuku Daikin. The
hourly wage is high, but it takes a long time to hit, and the
position where the opponent's accumulated damage is low is especially easy to be unwound.
The top throw is now named Air Inferno, but
it is launched with a blaster, but it has a high blow-off power or it may involve Pasha with a plaster
.  Music]
And there is a special throw. Hell Gate It
's
an image of being able to go back to the front while crouching, which is a powerful after-diagonal front. Of course, the
damage is great.
And it may be easy to shoot down out.
And although it is familiar to original fans, you can use the so-called Shoryuken command to perform special techniques.
When you enter a command, the Fengjin step will appear. A
technique to squeeze into the opponent while also aiming at the upper body. You
can input continuously.
The technique of flipping the opponent up is
simply higher in power, but I will go to the combo
The range is wider than it looks because it moves forward in combination with the dash by
input. It is the fastest wind sword, such as pressing the attack button at the same time as the last diagonally lower input
.  In the
original, the input reception time was 1 frame, but it is sweeter than that. It is one of the hard techniques
with a long course and a thunder god system strong foot bath at the time of the wind god step
.
It is also effective to incorporate it in the combo. It is
easier to overcome than it is because it causes invincibility.If
you put this out at midnight, it
will take attack power and it will be an example drive of the command version.
The
movement is 7 and I tell Lee the spiral phantom guest who puts in the front, but since the
spiral phantom guest starts from the top, I receive a combo after telling
it.  There is also a one-sided overcoming.
Finally, one special fascinating technique is that the
horizontal appeal is a quadruple combo called Majin Tear Prefecture.
Unlike the original, no complicated button input is required. There
is almost no practicality.  It can't be used in a match against someone, but if it hits, it's a bit of an interesting move in the distance,
so it
's the strongest of all the fighter's appeals
.
That's all. I think this is the individuality of the fighting game, and I'm
making it so that
it has a combo-oriented aspect.  There are almost no combos that can be surely hit because the results will come out, but it
is better to develop a combo that is easy to celebrate to some extent.
However, if you use a
long combo, it will be done by a third party, so it is easier to win if you apply the destructive power of the
repulsion.  However, the
dedicated stage is Mishima Dojo, rather
than Kazuya's Dojo, but Heihachi's Dojo. Stage where there were various things
[Music] As you
can see, the four corners are blocked by walls and ceilings.
Of course you can't shoot it down yet, but strong blows and direct coaties will break the walls and ceiling
. It's
relatively safe until it breaks, but it's a dangerous zone after it breaks.
[Music]
Damage to the walls and ceiling is heavy with the opponent's breath.  By the way,
when they break, you can't take a passive role. When
all of them break, it looks like this.
I think the broken walls and ceiling will heal naturally for some reason.
I omitted the display in the explanation, but there is a hay bee in the center
. 8 It reacts to rising and shooting down.
Please defeat a different new bargain.
Of course, it can be washed or the end point. It will be outdoors as a whole.
By the way, although it is a small story, there is a
fire eye.
I'd like to go to the other team 5 people who were
dropped by processing It's a group of victims
[Applause]
[Music]
First of all, don't break the wall. Make armor.
If you don't want to hurt too much, you can't help it.
[  Music]
I'm going to reduce the number of remaining aircraft for the time being
It's tough to say that I want to go with exactly the same power, but is
n't it the genie captain dog?
It's nice to have explained the computer burger
[music]
properly.
Oh
[applause]
[music]
I can't bring
it. I hate being targeted from diagonally above.
Kusumi 67 I can't go through. I'm not
good at it.
[Music]
Let's do it again.  There was a
car in front of me
pop crotch
[music] It's an
effort, but
it's the first person to eat 49 pars, so 4 more
[music]
Let's use it
well, avoid it well.
It's dangerous if it was Khan or the
target. Tsumugi
b
[Music] It's
said that it's a setting.
This is bad
[Music]
But I knew that this one has a better range
No, I'll do
something like this Faster review After twist 4 1. Angel and devil Where cancer
This position is very  It's good, it's
close to the edge of the screen
And this
Marus is big so that it doesn't change fish
[Music]
There's actually no house here in the
garden.
Yes, thank you for your hard work. It
was a pity that I couldn't get revenge on the proceedings. The
setting level was lined up
.
I hope you get it.
That
's all. It's a topic of music. Tekken has hundreds of songs because there are many series, but I narrowed it down like this.
All 39 songs.
This music is extremely many.  It
's one of the titles that has been going on for more than a quarter of a century, so it has a long history.
By the way, this winning pose is Tekken 7 town
car
v This is Tekken 56-chome
Cars, then democracy
v The first Tekken morning dew pose It's a little nostalgic,
but I'll show you the color variations
2 colors are only for flame embroidered dogi
7 p is a color that is conscious of Hitoshi Kazama
Booth color is coat 6 t is with tuxedo from the time of Tekken 2
8 p is gold pika that was in the original Tekken  There is such an image by customization.
By the way, Kirby copy looks like this
You can also see the appearance of blocking the devil blaster A
new spirits board will also be added
10 types including the fair were picked up by
Hitoshi Kazama  Spirits can be strengthened for security by setting it to level 99.
Also, it is always on sale at low 8 same size. If you stick to low 8-2, you can
be supported by body 8 Osuka.
Introducing the infighters
[Music]
Ah ah ah
[Applause]
[Music]
Yeah Yeah
This time, everything has a strong habit, or
it can be used as a single unit or with a
smasher.  In particular, there is a sidewalk system, isn't it?
The main character of Skyrim is called Dragon Ball. In the
original, it is sometimes
called "Kazuya Mishima" or "Auntie Key", but the crazy dragon bone is an English translation of Dovakin.
Dovakin is the bloodline of the original dragon and later,
and if you buy Shanti, you can add songs.
Half gd Hero's song called Burning Town will be in the other category.
[Music] The
main delivery date is
June 30th.  If you have Fighter Pass Ball 2, you can receive it as it is and you
can buy it as a single unit.
It will take some time, but we can expect the appearance of the fighter of Fighter Pass vol 2.
It is quite strange that Nintendo will make a figure of Kazuya Mishima,
but
various Amigos will be released at the time of viewing
now.  I've made various fighters and stages. It
was a challenging task for
me to combine various old and new games into one work. If you think about it, it's been nearly 10 years since the development of 4 from smartphones started.  It ’s been a long time since I
’ve been with
you for a long time.
First of all, I hope you enjoy Kazuya Mishima until
then. It is
[Music]